[Music]
Apple as you may have read the company
Apple has been having some public
relations problems the New York Times
and 60-minutes both ran stories about
the high number of worker suicides at
Apple's assembly plant in China well
today Apple responded by launching a new
product they think could really help
with this serious problem when we heard
there was a problem we moved fast worker
suicides in our China facility
unacceptable
we brought the concerned team together
and said how do we change this nothing
seemed right so instead of looking for
an answer
we made one introducing the Apple inet
the most digitally advanced worker
suicide prevention caching device ever
made the Apple inet revolutionizes the
safety net its trajectory sensor
the calibrates the tension and bounces
him right back to his place in the
assembly no lost time
no productivity drop the old analog
catch nets were too wide and let's some
of our younger workers through but
behind that narrow gauge construction
guarantees than ever under the pump and
sent back I like that the baby lives
back to work
you
[Applause]